there's so much poetry if you got to
know him
just the way he speaks
I remember one time
The Roots was having a jam session in
L.A hello Amir
and backstage I saw Jay-Z and a
photographer came up and said guys can
we get a picture it was him and his wife
Beyonce
and we all
right guys relax would you
[Applause]
and we all grouped together for a
picture me Jay and Beyonce and I stood
between them and I put my arms around
him and Jay grabbed me and moved me to
the side and grabbed his wife by the
hand and said the rose
between the thorns
and has been taking a picture Jay says
to me
he was having a lot of pressure on you
to say funny [ __ ] all the time
and I looked at Jay and I said well you
must have a lot of pressure on you
say cool [ __ ] all the time
[Applause]
and Jay looked at me and said
it ain't no pressure I just do it
that's right
and I looked at jail and said my God man
he just did it again
oh I'm your friend
and your van
I'm honored that I got a chance to know
you you embody
black Excellence how great we can be and
I am honored
to be the [ __ ] that gets to say to my
[ __ ]
welcome to the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame
[Applause]